20% d'intentions de vote pour françois
fillon derrière alain juppé crédité de
36% et nicolas sarkozy à 26%
ce serait la hiérarchie du premier tour
selon le dernier sondage aux docks ça en
attendant le dernier débat entre les
huit candidats ce jeudi 17 novembre les
responsables yvelinois de la primaire
attendent une mobilisation importante
avec un impact des élections américaines
s'étaient fait aux états unis ta
permettent à cette personne disant ben
oui les sondages donnent alain juppé 1er
2e sarkozy mais pourquoi pas aller voter
pour peut-être changer la donne
on l'a entendu encore ce week end sur
les marchés où les gens ont dit baisse
ça va nous mobiliser peut-être encore
plus pour montrer que la personne qui
peut être dans leur coeur était en 3 ou
4 ème position d'un risque peut-être de
passer en seconde position
il ya énormément d'attentes au niveau du
peuple français et je crois qu'on a
véritablement une alternance le
rapportait qu on pourrait être surpris
par le taux de participation
dernière ligne droite pour les
préparatifs du 1er tour avec 264 bureaux
de vote dans les yvelines en milieu
rural on regroupe bien entendu les
villages pour dans un seul et même
bureau donc il peut y avoir quatre cinq
villages regroupés et il y a des
affichettes qui seront installés apposé
sur la porte d'entrée de chacune de ces
mairies dans lesquelles il n'y a pas de
bureaux de vote pour que les électeurs
puissent le le savoir facilement les
résultats c'est une originalité remonte
directement à la haute autorité
c'est à dire qu'il n'y aura pas de
résultats le soir commune par commune au
département par département c'est la
haute autorité qui centralise tous les
résultats
les bureaux de vote seront ouverts dès 8
heures ce dimanche 20 novembre pour une
fermeture prévue à 19h